[Music]
we now think of a mall clooney as a
glamorous fashion icon but remember she
has a day job as a human rights lawyer
the noose around free speech is
tightening by the day his eleven cases
she's working on and she was teaching at
Columbia and still she she's still very
much like well I'd I'd like to wear that
dress and it's crazy
Matt Damon met his wife Luciana when she
was a single mom bartending in Miami
today their parents - four girls and
Lucy has also become a fashionista
do you have any say in what she gets to
wear for the red carpet or does she even
consult you no no no that's way above my
pay grade she doesn't want my advice
and if bull star Michael Weatherly ever
feels under the weather no worries
his wife boy Jana is a primary care
physician we met and I just noticed that
she wasn't wearing any makeup her hair
was in a ponytail and she was drinking
water in a bar and I thought whose bad
and it turned out she was a medical
student and now she's a doctor and we
have two kids modern families Julie
Bowling's husband Scott is a real-estate
investor and software developer julianna
margulies his husband keith is a
harvard-educated attorney that came in
handy when she played a lawyer on The
Good Wife
but those racy love scenes with Josh
Charles she says it was all good as far
as the spouses were concerned I said to
my husband you know it's one of those
scenes honey where I don't think you
should watch and he doesn't care he's
like please I don't care
and he goes but I'll send Sophie flowers
so they're both both both the partners
are on the same page it's very sweet
that could be a challenge yes it could
be by the way a couple other people who
are married to a non Hollywood types
NCIS LA stars um Chris O'Donnell his
wife Caroline was an elementary school
teacher they've got five kids in hey LL
Cool J has four kids with his beautiful
wife Simone who's a jewelry designer and
she does great stuff such a great couple
of you
[Music]
you